so we're going into a store which is
just a couple blocks away from where the
clashes are because they look like
they're getting closing
is that a lot yeah audience the horns in
the handbag so how does the Huntsville
in the bay like another issue her even
though FEMA wash your hands and stay
like at home but Rappahannock
W Palestinian is dr. tiller patella
modeled in the ilaha illah the illah
Dalek in retina Yanni we didn't have a
shit what a pain on how the shit I would
not another sheer magnitude irritability
like not in the East we do in each be
Salaam my confer to that my country
column my phone vehicle might be
this is mom over here Pahlavi no bananas
a little communist for remember Murphy
Bedelia and Ayane low indicator
we're in the occupied West Bank town of
Hebron right now we're clashes have just
broken out between Palestinian
protesters and Israeli soldiers heparin
is the epicenter of the tense